Welcome back!
Yes.
I'm scared!
Yeah, I became the juggler.
Look, you can do this.
I'm scared of...
I don't know!
Good morning!
I'm scared of...
I don't know.
I'm not very good with card games.
And...
And stuff.
So I'm nervous!
But I felt like...
I want to know what Bellatio is like.
But I also...
Don't find myself ever trying it off stream.
So I...
I'm forcing myself...
Here and now.
Just take your time.
I don't know.
Try not to be so...
Critical!
Looking sharp today, Minto.
Thank you.
How much was because of the clown girl art?
I did not see any clown girl art.
What are you talking about?
What's on your feed?
My cute adorable Minto, I hope you have a lot of fun.
Thank you!
I have not seen anything of...
This game.
I'll be honest, I know literally like...
All I've seen is...
I've seen some advertisements for it and that's about it.
I don't know anything.
Thanks for the 5 gifted!
Okay, I'll sing happy birthday and then we'll start.
Logan, thanks for the 5 gifted.
You're going into this blind?
Yeah?
Wait.
Is that something in the game?
Yeah, I'm going in blind.
I don't know anything.
I'll be trying to beat my best hand, E38.
That means nothing to me!
I don't know what that means!
I don't...
Yes, actually...
I don't know!
Liar in chat.
Why?
Hi!
Uh-oh.
Minto, hi.
Hello!
Don't worry, Minto.
Once you get the clown, the game gets real...
Has this game been falsely advertised to me?
Hi, Minky.
It's my birthday tomorrow.
Could I have a special Metal Gear birthday a day in advance?
Love me not!
Since I'm not streaming tomorrow.
Happy birthday!
Congratulations!
Salutations!
Happy birthday!
May your sky stay blue!
Happy birthday to you!
Love me not!
Happy birthday!
This is a backseater game.
No, no!
No!
No backseating!
Unless I ask.
I want to learn properly.
No backseating!
Maybe I should put that on my head.
Yeah, no help.
No...
Help.
Unless I ask.
No help.
I'd rather not.
Thanks for the 10 gift card!
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Thank you.
What was I going to say?
I don't remember.
Thank you for the 20 gift card!
Thank you!
Thank you so much!
Thank you for the gift card.
So yeah.
How long before she asks?
Stop!
No!
Okay.
Why are you pixelated?
I don't know.
I felt like I wanted to join in on the game.
Is it too much?
I thought maybe it was immersion.
I'll turn it off.
More pixel.
Let's see how pixel-y we can get.
It's just like my Japanese doujinshi.
You can't even see my... Oh my god!
You can only see my nose.
Okay guys, this is how we're playing the game today.
Okay, okay, okay.
Don't say dream woman.
I just told me I'm not allowed to backseat or she'll kill me.
But I really hope you have fun with this.
Blacho was my game of the year.
No!
Game of the year was Astro Bot.
I'm sorry.
I'm sorry you lost.
Oh my gosh, get over it.
I'm sorry.
Astro Bot won!
Gosh!
Jeez!
But thank you.
Alright, let's get into it.
I'm nervous.
I'm scared!
Is this game scary?
The people demand crunchy looking mint.
Send your head below.
Thanks for the time.
Good play!
Hello there.
My name is Jimbo.
I'm here to help you learn how to play.
Okay.
Your goal is to earn chips and to defeat the enemy blind.
Is that his name?
This is named blind?
Mr. Blind?
Blind is a poker concept.
Okay, we're already off to a really great start.
I thought the guy's name...
I was like, why did your parents hurt you?
Why do they hate you?
Hello child.
We care not to see you.
You are blind.
They're cursing him from the start.
Okay.
What's scary is your free time disappearing forever.
I have other means of things that cause that to happen.
Here, this here is a small blind.
You only need to score 300 chips to beat it.
Select a small blind to start the round.
You earn chips by playing poker hands.
I don't know poker.
I don't know poker!
Only four people have died playing this game.
None of them are Ghostmates, so the odds are in your favor.
What if I'm the first?
I want to go down in history.
You earn chips by playing poker hands.
Each poker hand earns a base amount of chips multiplied by some...
Oh, I thought that said nut.
Molt?
What does that mean?
Oh, like a multiplier.
Multiplier.
See your poker hands in the run info area.
Along with other info about your current run.
Oh my gosh, they help you.
Four of a kind.
Why is that three there?
Who invited?
Bro thinks he's part of the team.
Five cards in a row.
All consecutive ranks with all cards sharing the same suit.
He's emotional support.
A three of a kind and a pair.
Alright.
We got the thruple and the couple.
That's a full house, alright.
Poker, I barely even know her.
Flush.
Five cards that share the same suit.
Okay.
Five cards in a row.
Okay, just normal.
Okay, straight flush is when they're all the same suit.
And then straight is they're just, they don't all have the same suit.
Straight flush is me talking to a pretty lady.
Three of a kind.
It's the six and the five, you get out of here.
Three cards with the same rank.
They may be played up to two other unscored cards.
Two pair, okay?
Pair, okay?
High card.
If the played hand is not of any of the above hands, only the highest ranked card scores.
I have to have some real bad luck for that.
Couldn't beat me.
Cards also earn you chips.
Hover over to see.
Next.
Chips, chips, chips, chips.
Okay.
Okay, chips, chips, chips, chips.
Now select up to five cards to play and press play hand.
We have these three.
Wait, what is it?
Uh...
Hold on.
Hold on, I'm not even looking at chat.
Don't tell me anything.
I could...
Oh, there it is.
No, it wasn't three of a kind.
Oh my gosh, I don't have shit.
It's like...
I have a pair.
Wait.
Wait, select up to five cards.
Oh, there it is, okay.
What's this one?
Oh, this is just the bigger bets.
What's a voucher?
No vouchers are deemed in this run.
I'm going couponing.
Okay.
We might be cooked.
I told you!
I told you.
Wait, how do I...
Wait, so I just select up to five.
What if I just play all of them?
Okay.
Goodbye cards.
You can also discard up to five cards.
Oh, what if I...
I don't like the guy that is...
He's faceless, so he's a little scary.
Bye bye.
Thank you.
Careful, you only have a limited number of hands and discards per round.
He's scary.
Faceless guy.
Earn 300 chips before you run out of hands to win this round.
Good luck.
Oh, I have to...
What?
Oh, okay.
Well, I have a four consecutive.
But they're not the same.
They're just like kind of the same.
Yeah, I'll make them all different so it's a little fancy.
Oh, play?
I don't know what the fuck I'm doing.
What did you guys say?
No!
Oh, it has to be five?
Wait, what?
Minto, have you played poker?
No.
It said that...
Wait, it said that...
I give up.
How do I get out of this?
If I give all my hands away...
They'll never...
They'll never have anything.
I don't want to be here anymore.
Throw it...
Throw it away.
Wait, what was that?
Oh, wow.
It even says like...
Hey, you threw away that.
She's going full Jonkler.
I'm going to burn it down!
I'm so confused.
So...
Okay.
So like, this would be a pair and then I just throw in a random card?
Why do I throw in a random card?
What was the point?
It didn't even give me any extra points.
People said I need to throw five.
But I threw five and it didn't even do anything.
You don't have to.
Then why did everybody say you have to?
Why did everybody say...
Oh, Minto, you didn't...
You didn't...
You have to have a fifth card.
That's what the rules...
That's what the tutorial said.
Why did they say that?
Chat...
Chat is too...
It's too much text.
TLDR.
TLDR, you guys.
Seriously, there's just too much text on the screen right now.
You guys are just...
You guys are like spamming the same thing over and over again.
Mods, can we get in here?
Can we get someone in here?
Okay, anyway.
Two pairs.
Wait, so I can either play my hand or...
Or discard.
Oh, how did I lose?
Wait, bluffing?
What happened?
Oh, you have a certain number of hands?
They didn't tell you that.
What was this?
Black stake.
Orange stake.
Stake.
Green stake.
I'm green.
Okay, anyway.
Alright.
I'll actually try this time, you guys.
I'll actually try.
Okay.
Oh, stake.
That's what I'm thinking.
Stake.
Okay.
So, if I'm just like...
Two pair.
Or if I'm like a pair.
I have nothing else.
I can just throw this out.
And then if I'm like...
Oh, I want to discard the two.
I can just do whatever.
It doesn't have to be like...
Stop saying run info.
I literally read it.
I read it.
Stop saying it.
It just won't help with the score.
Okay, yeah.
That's what I figured.
No, you did not.
What are you talking about?
I literally looked at these.
Yeah, this is why AstroBot won in this loss.
So true.
Anyway.
Okay.
I thought you were really focused.
I went to...
Wait.
I said I went to go get water.
Oh, I didn't?
No, I said it though.
I think maybe I said it...
Maybe I'm muted.
I said it...
Wait.
I thought I said it before I muted.
Oopsie.
Astro, I said it...
You guys are not mind readers.
How could you not read my brain?
I literally said it.
How
many hands do I have?
Oh, three.
And four discards.
Okay.
So I can like play this.
It's like...
If I...
Okay.
I should have done a hand camera.
Oh!
I almost have...
If only I had...
Can I...
Can I tell this one to turn into a four?
Can I say...
Can I give it money?
And say...
Turn into a four.
I can just discard it.
But what if I don't get it?
Discard.
Oh!
Oh, wait.
No!
Banish it to the shadow realm.
Use your discards.
Should I do it again?
Okay.
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna discard the ten too.
Oh, but what...
But what if I...
Oh, I threw away my jack.
Okay, get discard.
This game hates me!
Wait, I have a question.
If I...
Okay, say I'm like...
If I discard all of these cards at once...
I have one discard left, so it's not the number.
It's just the...
So a discard is...
You...
It counts like a hand.
Okay, correct.
Okay, okay.
Well, I have...
I have two pairs.
I don't think I'll get enough if I...
I don't know if I'll get enough.
Oh, no!
Wait, does that mean...
All the fours are gone?
I could get a nine.
I'm too stupid for all this.
Don't worry, me too.
That's why I didn't want to play this on stream.
Oh, that means they're all of...
Oh, they haven't...
Okay, okay.
So the one is that...
What the hell then?
This game hates me.
Okay, one more.
Actually...
You know what?
I don't care.
I don't care!
We're so close!
I'm gonna get rid
of...
I'm gonna get rid of it all.
I'm gonna get rid of all four of these.
Wait, what's a flush?
What's a flush?
Wait, a flush?
Five cards...
One, two, three, four...
Just kidding!
I'm playing it!
My friends are gaslighting me to pick this game up.
Should I?
Only if you want to feel like a real bozo.
I get three dollars?
I'm gonna go buy ice cream!
Wait, cash out.
Nicely done!
Now that you're flush with cash, you can buy some new cards from the shop.
Try buying this handsome devil.
What about the empress?
Who's that lovely lady?
I have three dollars.
I have three dollars though.
I don't want to buy that.
Jimbo insists.
This is one of the 150 jokers you can add to your run.
Every joker does something different.
Junk card.
Oh, I thought...
Oh, because I thought I started out with no money.
This one adds plus four molt to every hand you play.
Wow, be picky.
You can only carry five joker cards at a time.
Oh!
Enhances two selected cards to molt cards.
This tarot card is a consumable.
This one will enhance your playing cards.
Hold on to it.
You can carry up to two consumable cards with you at a time.
If you save up enough, you can buy a voucher.
Vouchers passively upgrade your run.
What?
I just beat Champion Victor from Lies of P while watching...
After fighting him all day.
Congratulations!
Vouchers are restocked after you defeat the boss blind.
Check out both of the booster packs.
They're full of goodies.
Buffoon.
Let's move on to the next round.
Okay.
Big Blo-BB.
That's if Big Boss lost both his eyes.
Not just one.
Oh
you Big Blind.
Selecting the Big Blind will earn some cash.
Or choose to skip it to get a tag.
Each tag has a unique effect.
He's just saying words.
What does that mean?
But keep an eye on the Boss Blind.
It has an ability you'll need to plan around.
Discards two random cards per hand play.
I discard two random cards?
If you beat it then the ante goes up and all blinds become harder.
Beat ante A to win.
Now choose your path.
Gives one dollar per... what?
Gives one dollar per unused discard this run.
We'll give you one dollar.
So it gives me a dollar?
It gives me a single dollar?
I think maybe I should try the Big Blind.
The hook is looking a little...
She's looking a little...
Nice.
Okay, I'll try it.
When you get more cards, remember you can rearrange them.
Jokers trigger in order from left to right.
And make sure you use...
I don't even... What does this do?
Enhances two select cards to multiple cards.
So it makes the cards...
More multipliable?
Just gives you a bonus.
Okay.
Select up to two cards in your hand and press use on the tarot card to enhance them.
Select these guys.
And
then...
There is no...
Use.
Where does Among Us come into this?
Okay.
Oh gosh, I gotta look over these again.
Because you guys saw the flush.
I didn't see that at all.
Okay, flush is five cards.
Three of a kind and a pair is a full house.
I gotta remember the couple and the throuple.
The couple and the throuple.
It's a full house.
What's the song for the full house?
I never watched that show.
Thanks for the gift in!
Thank you guys!
Everywhere you look.
Everywhere you go.
There's always a mean girl.
Everywhere you look.
Everywhere you go.
You can't escape.
Okay.
Four of a kind, that's easy.
Straight flush is easy.
Straight is easy.
Three of a kind is easy.
Two pair, easy.
Pair, easy.
High card, sure.
Wait, high card?
Only the highest ranked card scores.
So it's just like, hey, I'm an ace.
Straight is easy?
Yeah, to remember.
It's just five cards in a row.
Consecutive ranks.
I'm not saying it's easy to get.
I'm saying it's easy to remember.
Two!
Wait, okay, hold on.
Three of a kind, a pair.
I wish we had four of a kind and then a random guy.
That would be fun.
It's like, hi, we're so... I mean, we're four in consecutive and then we added this guy just for the fun of it.
And then Joker.
Do I pull him or do I always have him?
Wild card, okay.
I'm going to...
Discard this two.
He's always there, okay.
Wanted to try and get a six and maybe an eight.
I don't know.
One, two, three.
Oh wait, it's a...
Straight is five card.
Five.
No, straight is five.
One, two, three, four.
And then one, two, three.
Ace is one.
But what does that have to do with it?
With a straight.
When it's five cards.
Wait.
I still don't have a straight though.
Because it would be one.
I don't have a two.
I don't have two.
I didn't discard a two.
I discarded three.
I had two threes.
And it was like another one.
You guys are...
Go away.
You're being bad.
I banish you.
I don't look anymore.
You've lost all your privileges.
Actually.
Let's see who the real people are.
What do you mean?
Anyway, I don't know what the hell I'm doing.
I don't know anymore.
I'm just gonna...
I don't know.
Stop it!
No!
I'm scared.
I'm scared to do anything.
This is why I don't play card games.
Except blackjack.
I like blackjack.
I don't know how this game works so no elf.
Me neither.
Okay, I'll bring you guys back.
I'm still not looking at chat.
Why am I getting bugged?
Don't attack the super!
Wait, the straight is...
Not the... No.
Flush.
There's five cards.
I think I might get rid of these and try for flush.
But I'll keep the elves.
Because it's hot.
I think.
Maybe.
You son of a bitch.
1, 2, 3, 4!
I don't want to get rid of this guy because we put the multiplier on him.
What do I do?
I'm gonna have no more discards at this point.
Or get a 10.
Oh, because of this?
Yeah, because 11...
1, 2, 3, 4.
Oh, it would be big money, right?
Wait, what is it?
The straight...
But flush is more points.
Yeah, it's technically more points.
Then a straight.
I think going for the flush is smarter than going for the straight.
I.M.H.O.
Get rid of the ace.
Guys, do I get rid of the ace?
Oh, but then...
Hold on.
We are doing spades, so...
If I go for the flush...
Let's go for the flush.
I made up my mind.
I made up my mind!
1, 2, 3, 4, 5!
One hand baby!
Three!
Thank you!
I want to gamble.
Choose one of up to three tarot cards to be used immediately.
Oh wait, where did my bozo pack go?
Reroll costs money.
Converts up to three selected cards to hearts.
That could be good.
Level up two pair.
Wait, level up two pair.
Plus one multiplier and 20 chips.
So it just adds more 20 chips?
I think this one is better.
Makes a two pair hand better.
Oh, oh, oh, okay, okay, I get it, I understand now.
Ah, I see, I see, I thought I meant...
Okay, okay, okay.
Well, we can get both.
Buy...
Wait, buy and use?
What if I just buy it?
What does a buy and use mean?
Does it like immediately put it into my...
Thing?
It applies it right away.
Is this permanent?
Yes?
Oh, for this run.
Oh.
Boo!
Okay.
Okay, okay.
This is the boss, right?
I'm scared.
Oh, but...
Oh, big blind!
The hook.
Discards two random cards per hand played.
Wait,
I have to get rid of them now?
Oh, this guy is back.
Oh,
I could do a flush.
1, 2, 3, 4...
What if I made him into a heart?
And then it would be the multiplier.
And I can make the king also.
Use?
Oh, wait.
Wait, 1, 2...
I have a question.
So, for flush...
Five cards in the same unit.
Do you get extra money if, say, like see for this.
It's an ace and a king and a ten.
If it was like a one and a two and a three...
Does that...
Make it more money?
Yes, it's more points.
Okay.
Thank you.
I said no help unless I ask.
So if I change these two, then it will be more money.
What?
The higher the card, the more chips they add.
Okay.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5.
I wanted to use this multiplier because what if they threw it away, you know?
Maybe I'm too good at this game.
This joker gains...
0...
0.025 multiplier for each card sold.
Resets when boss blind is defeated.
This joker gains plus one multiplier per consecutive hand played without scoring face card.
What's a voucher?
Oh.
I have enough.
The bus?
The bus is good.
So face card is a jack, queen, king?
Can someone explain this to me like I'm a Vtuber?
It
gets stronger if you don't play face cards.
Tiara, my man.
Thank you.
If you don't play fancy cards.
If you don't score face cards.
Imagine if Minto was a Vtuber.
Resets if you place a face card though.
And what are these packs?
I'm so curious.
I want to know what's inside.
I want to know.
But they are just standard packs.
I miss the Bozo one.
Thanks for the solitaire stream.
Here we go!
Gold card.
Six of spades.
Plus six chips.
Three dollars if this card is held in your hand at the end of the round.
Plus nine chips.
Plus eleven chips.
Plus thirty extra chips.
I feel a gold card is...
Fancy.
I just have to get this card and then hold on to it.
But what if I want to use it?
That would be so sad.
Do not take the nine.
Don't tell me what to do!
Multiply your supers if you don't play the Flesh Tuber card.
That's it!
I guess we'll go for the six.
People kept saying about the bus.
I guess I'll buy it.
The bus.
I have one dollar.
What's this?
Upgrade Flesh by three levels.
My toilet?
Wait!
How long?
Wait, so if I lose, I lose everything?
Oh my god.
If I lose, I lose everything?
Till game over.
Oh my god.
This game is confusing me.
It's a roguelike.
Oh my god.
This is kind of... Upgrade the Flesh by three levels.
That seems kind of big.
That seems kind of big, right?
Green.
Angel, thanks for the gift.
I'm
gonna not do it just because you said three levels is poggers.
One, two, three, four, five.
Look at that.
Wait, so...
How do I use this?
If I like...
Like I...
Oh, it's automatic?
Oh, it's passive.
Oh, okay.
This one wasn't passive though, was it?
I can't remember how I used it.
It was?
But it told me to pick the cards.
Seven, six, five, four.
So...
Oh,
I have four.
One, two, three, four, five.
Yeah, I guess this works.
Doesn't really matter.
Maybe.
Okay.
You know what's also big?
My P-Pair.
Which at high levels can score higher than a four of a kind or straight Flesh.
I hope you're feeling better, Minky.
Thank you.
Glad you liked the lore video.
Okay, where are we at now?
I have two pairs.
But if I use...
Stinky...
Stinky faceless men.
Stinky jacks.
I don't get my multiplier if I have you here.
Play the jacks out of spite.
Trying to figure out what I want to make with these.
Because we have like a setup for something.
Something around there, maybe.
If you play a face, the bus ride stops.
No, bus driver.
Thank you, bus driver.
Why did you guys tell me to get this?
These are the big money.
The gold six, true.
Let's get rid of these guys.
Goodbye.
I
didn't even buy the gold six.
I bought the ace.
Muffin is a faceless jack.
Do I just get rid of him again?
Magic spell for passing kidney stones.
Go ride Thunder Mountain at Disney's...
Disney Park.
Goodbye.
I'm just going to do this.
I think.
I don't even know what I'm trying to make.
I might throw away the three at that point then too.
Play.
I
don't realize how much you get from these points.
Until it happens.
Five bucks, let's go.
Let's go.
Plus twelve multiplier if played hand contains a straight.
Little bean.
Plus five hand size.
Reduces by one every round.
So I would start out with five extra cards.
Is what that means.
But it decays.
I feel
like this one is way too specific, right?
I don't have to buy anything.
It doesn't decay fast.
They are kind of meh.
I'm seeing people are split on the bean.
People are...all bean opposers raise your hand.
All bean...all bean...all bean...opposers raise your hand.
I'd say that's the majority.
Next round!
What do we get?
Mega Arcana pack!
That sounds exciting.
Choose two of up to five tarot cards to be used immediately.
Mega Arcana!
Get money.
Is it possible to beat this game without any upgrades?
Like in the tougher levels?
I feel like not really, right?
How far have you gotten?
I'm just going to play it.
Because I'm still learning and I want to do as many rounds as I can to learn.
How many levels...how far have you gotten?
There is a joker-less thing.
Joker-less run.
People are true masochists, I swear.
Goodbye family!
I'm murdering this entire...
Wait, oh my gosh.
If I get a ten...of hearts?
If I get a ten of hearts...
Wait, when would the bus come back?
When would the bus come back?
It's better than the bus.
Right?
If only I had bought that other joker.
Wait, would that be a straight?
Which is that?
Straight?
Straight flush?
Welcome to the addiction.
Thanks.
Yeah, I could sell it.
True.
I could sell it and then it wouldn't just disappear.
I would get money for it.
I feel like it's worth it.
Like I can sell all four of these cards.
It doesn't disappear.
Oh, it doesn't vanish?
Oh, it just stops working for...
It just resets.
I'm selling these.
Discard!
I got it.
Oh!
Holy shit!
I played a royal flush!
I got an achievement!
I told you guys!
We have icy...Oh my gosh!
Ice Joker!
Plus two chips for each remaining card in deck.
Ice Joker.
Or...
This joker gains plus three multiplier when any booster pack is skipped.
Like if I don't buy this?
Spectra, that's mean!
Choose two of up to four spectral cards.
If you buy and skip...Wait, what?
Oh, if you buy it...What?
That's so evil.
So you have to buy?
You have to buy the pack and then just be like, nah, this sucks and just skip it?
This bus sucks.
No help is only when I don't ask for help.
But if I ask questions, if I don't understand something, then of course help is okay.
But if you're like, VTuber!
You should play the jack instead!
Then that's...This is choose one of up to five tarot cards.
Choose two of the spectral cards.
What's a spectral...We don't even know what that is!
Why did this play?
What's happening?
Let me off this bus!
Grim.
Destroy one random card in your hand.
Add two random enhanced aces to your hand.
Add foil holographic or polychrome effect to one selected card in hand.
Fifty chips plus ten multiplier.
That's huge!
Oh my god.
Aura.
Hex.
Add polychrome to a random joker.
Destroys all other jokers.
I only have one.
Oh wait, no, just kidding.
I'm an idiot.
Converts all cards in hand to a single random rank minus one hand size.
What?
Oh, if I sell the bus and do this...
It would be plus four and then 1.5?
I can choose two.
I think I'm gonna choose the aura one for sure.
But then...
Oh, I see how it reset.
I see.
I understand now.
Welcome to membership.
Thank you.
Converts all cards to a random rank?
Wait, so they would all be the same number?
You get that.
Why is it showing these?
I'm so confused.
Oh, so I can like put it on the ace.
That would be huge actually.
That would be huge.
Putting it on the ace would be really good.
What is it?
Foil.
So it's only in my hand.
I'm so confused.
Kill the bus.
It might be time to kill the bus.
But I can also get... Wait, I can get two random enhanced aces.
Wait a second, wait a second, wait a second...
If I do the aces, I would get two more aces.
And then...
And then if I just...
It could destroy your ace.
Oh, it couldn't.
We'd have to take the gamble.
How would I get... How would I get...
Look at that guy.
Wait.
If I pulled him then... Wait.
If I got the two enhanced and then I pulled another ace, I could get the... Wait, isn't it four of a kind?
Yeah, four of a kind.
I could get the four of a kind.
If I pulled one more.
You could make five of a kind.
I have a lot of aces.
One, two, three, four, five.
I could.
Should I try it?
You guys, should I try it?
Do we risk?
Do we gamble?
Let's go gambling!
That was so close.
That
was so close.
I have six dollars left.
Should I... I have a question.
What do chips do?
I have 108 of them.
What do they do?
How do I use them?
That's your score.
Actual points.
So, this would be good then, right?
To have.
Technically.
Okay, I'll buy it.
Alright, let's go.
Next round.
And it's the big boss.
The window.
All diamond cards are debuffed.
I don't have any of that, right?
Oh, diamond.
I'm sorry.
I was thinking like a foil card.
I was like...
Oh, you can get cards that are like diamond.
Where
did my other aces go?
I thought they were in my hand.
Oh, you still have to draw them.
Okay.
Alright, guys.
I think I just throw everything away.
I just go for...
I just go for the big ones.
Wait, let me keep that.
Let's go for the big ones.
Potential heart flush.
I know, that's why I'm like...
That's why I'm...
I'm calculating.
I think... ALL IN!
But it would still, even if it's...
Even if it's debuffed, it would still work, right?
Wait.
Full house.
What's this one?
What's a full house?
Three of a kind and a pair.
I mean, I could do this pair too.
I don't have any multiplier on it, so...
Do the 10s on the king.
Just so that we can get the multiplier.
Is it possible?
Yeah!
We got some funky looking things going on here.
I never get any tarot cards.
I don't understand what's going on in this game, but I appreciate the minter noise.
I don't know what's going on either.
If first hand of round is a single six...
Destroy it and create a spectral card.
Must have room.
What?
Everybody is screaming about DNA.
Hold on guys, let me read it.
If first hand of round has only one card...
Add a permanent copy to deck and draw it to hand.
What?
This is rare.
Jack, thanks for the ping.
I don't understand.
You can use it to copy cards.
You play one card and you copy it and then you put it...
And then it would put it in my deck and then I would draw it.
I would draw it immediately.
What's a celestial pack?
Three planet cards.
Yes, I'll try it.
How many of these can I have?
Oh, out of five.
Just kidding.
I see, I can read.
It's a free spectral pack.
I'm saving money.
He's like, hey, use me.
Use me.
Look at them, he's boss.
He's like, I can't stop looking up there.
I have like...
One, two, three, four... I have a straight.
I have a straight.
If only this...
If only...
If I...
So it says like first hand of round.
So if I discard anything...
Yeah, obviously that would be a new hand then, right?
Oh,
discards don't count.
So if I discard this ten and this six to try and maybe get...
Oh, and the king to try and maybe get one and ace and two?
Maybe...
Part nine.
OK, let's try it.
Discard.
Ace!
I
think that almost got me enough to win.
Oh, it's gone.
Oh, only once per round.
Oh yeah, you're so right.
Anyway...
We can still do this.
It doesn't matter which one.
Get rid of the red.
We can still do this.
I want the big money.
Aw, shucks.
We can get an extra chips though.
No, I can't.
That's five cards.
Anyway...
Yeah!
OK.
Wait, you get more money the less cards you play and not the higher your score is or is it both?
You make money by having hands left over.
The more hands left.
Oh, it's not your score then?
Oh, OK.
I'll remember that.
Plus a multiplier if player hand contains a pair.
Plus 30 chips for each remaining discard.
Oh, discard.
Oh...
I don't have enough for this one.
Hey guys, I don't have enough for it.
I have no money.
I could buy an Arcana pack.
I could sell a jaunt.
Yeah, I could sell one.
Um...
Jam, welcome to the membership.
Thank you.
No, I don't want to sell my bus.
I like my bus.
It's been helping me out.
I've gotten this far.
The bus...my bus pass is insane.
My bus...my bus...
My bus!
Thank you bus driver.
Wait, why is it saying negative right there?
Plus one Joker slot.
Wait, that's a bad part?
It adds a Joker slot so I would be able to maybe buy the bus back eventually?
We could sell the bus and get it again someday.
One day!
Hand contain a pair.
That's so specific.
Thanks for staying gifted.
Look we are at plus four multiplier.
I'm keeping it.
Whatever.
Next round.
What do we get?
Mega standard pack.
I'll
get rid of these and we'll just keep these for now.
If I get a nine...
But my ace.
Fish ace.
I actually don't really understand this one.
Legendary Joker in the bottom corner.
Wait, so I just can then play the same thing?
Oh, but then I have it for the next round, right?
Ok, wait, hold on.
What's better?
A straight or...
I don't have a full hat.
Wait.
Three of a kind and a pair.
I don't have that, do I?
I need to keep remembering that's a thing because I feel like that one is pretty good.
But I think this should be enough.
Maybe?
Our multiplier is kind of crazy.
You're creating new aces.
Oh, so if I then play it next round it will...
Should I pull for a better ace?
Maybe it will get a better ace in all...
Oh no, Junkler.
Ace babies.
That was your best ace?
Really?
You think so?
I feel like I have better aces.
Like this one, right?
Wait, what is this?
It's just... Oh, plus 50.
Just kidding.
It is my best.
You're right.
Level up three of a kind.
Oh, wow, it's a tarot card.
Plus 2 multiplier plus 20 chip.
Three of a kind.
I can pay for that.
Oh, planet.
Yeah, sorry.
One in two chances to create a tarot card when any booster pack is opened.
No!
Try an Arcana pack.
We can do the one of one.
Choose one of up to three tarot cards to be used immediately.
Choose two of up to five tarot cards to be used immediately.
Yeah, the voucher.
I don't want to use this one.
This one is fine, but I want to see others.
We have four dollars left.
What if we get another good card and I can't...
OK.
Open.
World.
Converts up to three selected cards to spades.
Oh, three dollars of this card is held in hand at the end of round.
Oh, selects... Enhances one selected card into a gold card.
OK, hold on.
Let me read.
Converts up to three selected cards to spades.
OK.
Enhances two selected cards to multicards.
Oh, we had the Empress before.
I didn't realize that these, like, buffs were permanent.
Thanks for the stream!
Also, your jokers trigger left to right, so it might be worth reordering them.
Yeah, permanent to the run.
Hell yeah, that's what I meant.
Chariot.
Enhances one selected card into a steel card.
1.5 card while this card stays in their hand.
Doubles money!
OK.
Now one more.
Doubles money earned.
I see.
OK,
anyway.
Let's see.
So, 1.5 multiplier while this card stays in your hand.
OK.
Hear me out.
Wait.
Hear me out!
The Ace.
We then...
Multiply.
We then... We then dupe it.
And then we will hold on to it.
Right?
Maybe... Wait.
It's a great strategy?
Maybe?
We can try it.
Why not?
Let's try it.
Anyway, let's go to the next round.
All heart cards are debuffed!
The head!
OK.
I'm scared.
Oh, I forgot to rearrange it.
My Aces are hearts.
You can move your jokers at any time.
So if I like... Let's see.
Does it matter actually?
I don't think so.
I got a flush.
What's a flush again?
Oh, five cards share the same unit.
That's so fucked up!
That's so messed up!
OK, let me just... Let me just play this.
Goodbye!
Goodbye.
That's so messed up.
Get five of a kind.
We can try.
Full house is three of a kind and a pair.
Yeah, we do have a three of a kind and a pair, but...
Full house.
Guys, it's not looking so good.
Guys, but we still have our pair!
We can do the three of a kind and a pair, right?
That's the full house.
It's OK.
We still got the full house.
I reached anti-four.
Hang a
bit.
Slowly but surely.
Just finished orientation for my new job.
Otsu!
Level up straight.
Plus three multiplier...
Oh, it's another planet.
Retrigger all played cards in final hand of round.
What does that mean?
Plus one hand size.
That's kind of huge though, right?
Oh, cards will score twice.
Final hand will score twice.
I think I'm going to get this one though.
Paintbrush.
So, would this...
I guess... OK, wait.
If it's a final round though, wouldn't that imply...
Oh, so it's like...
If I say I have the hands and I'm on the final hand.
The last hand.
It's not like if I...
Like the hand to win, right?
Only for your last hand.
If you have one hand left.
OK, OK, OK.
That could be like a clutch and all.
I feel like that could help.
Last in the store.
Thanks for the 10 gifted.
Survival Joker.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Panic button.
Yeah, yeah.
It could be good.
I feel we do have to be a little bit...
A little bit exclusive.
Since we have only one slot left.
But I don't hate this.
I could always sell it.
True.
But it doesn't sell for the same amount.
It does?
Or no?
It sells for like half.
It sells for half-ish.
I see.
It sells for $2?
That's not even half.
Rip off, rip off, rip off, rip off.
Why is the icon for this game Lord Farquaad?
On my desktop.
Not Jimbo.
This is Jimbo, right?
Look, look.
Hold on.
Windows Shift S.
This is on my desktop.
I just noticed it just now.
Lord Farquaad.
Have a virus.
Where is our Shrek pack?
Come on, Bilatro.
Get on it.
It's right there.
OK, I'm just gonna go to the next round.
Rerolls the boss blind.
All club cards are debuffed.
$10,000.
OK.
Oh.
I think I should hunt for a better one.
Fish for better.
I agree.
Are we gonna keep this?
Because we almost... We kind of have a little bit of a straight going on.
But I don't think I should keep him, maybe.
Grab plus 8 multiplier.
ABD, always be discarded.
Almost a flash?
Really?
1, 2, 3, 4.
I see.
Let's just get rid of these.
Wait, which is better?
Straight?
Oh, flash is technically better.
Maybe we should go by that instead then.
Let's go for that instead.
Discard!
What the hell?
Guys, this isn't looking good.
3, 4, 5.
I'm gonna play our flush.
Is that enough?
Close.
And last discard.
Yeah.
The pear will do it, probably, but...
It was on fire!
I thought I would get an achievement for that.
Happy Bellagio.
Thank you!
Now we just need to do that on...
On the...
The boss.
Money on sale.
Yeah, actually.
Let's see.
Played...
Sorry dealer, 5 aces.
Read them in wheat.
I can't believe that just happened.
Playing cards with heart suit will give plus 3 multiplier when scored.
Okay.
He's all here for Valentine's Day.
Let's do the hermit.
Buy and use.
We got more money.
The bozo pack!
Choose one of up to two joker cards.
What is the...
Joker card?
Should we try it?
Should we do the bozo?
Yeah, let's do it.
Let's try the bozo pack.
Plus 10 multiplier if played hand contains a flush.
This joker gains plus 3 chips per discarded diamond card.
Suit changes every round.
Oh...
Green tea, welcome to Mambo Shop!
Castle isn't bad.
Yeah, I do discard a lot.
Castle could be good and it changes so it doesn't have to be the same card every time.
I'm always just throwing stuff away.
I'm always just like, yeah, get out of here.
Let's try it.
If we don't like it, we sell it later.
I don't know.
Rerolls the boss blind.
I'll club cards.
Let's go.
What if I...
Try to get more aces.
Yeah, now discard for all aces.
Dang.
I guess this is good to have when we don't ride the bus anymore.
But since I'm riding the bus...
Okay, what is this?
Diamond card.
I'm only throwing away one of those, but that's okay.
Whatever, it doesn't matter.
Upgrade!
Shoot.
Oh shoot.
Hold on.
One, two.
Let's get rid of the people.
Get rid of the people.
Down with the...
Should I try for five?
Everything is coming at me.
I should have discarded these.
I'm an idiot.
That's okay though.
Score 10,000 chips in a single hand.
This joker gains 0.25 multiplier every time playing a card is added to your deck.
Wait, what?
Like...
So...
So with the DNA?
Like that?
Huge with DNA?
It sounds like it.
We have to sell someone though.
Hold on.
Earn $2 per discard.
If no discards are used by the end of the round.
No, but I used discards.
No, no, no, no, no.
Sell Jimbo!
Him!
Jimbo!
He's been with me this whole time.
Jimbo for holographic Jimbo.
It's not the same.
It's like having...
The Beatles playing on stage.
It's not the same.
He upgraded.
Is this like Jimbo becoming a VTuber?
Is it like he became a VTuber and now...
Yeah?
Okay.
He sells for $1.
Nobody wants him.
I thought he was gonna curse me.
I'm not gonna lie.
Hey, Jimbo.
Wait, should I... Does order matter here?
Should I put it like behind the DNA?
All the way to the right?
Okay, okay.
Yeah, because then... Okay, okay, okay.
Wow, there's so much to keep track of here.
Choose one of up to five planet cards.
Only one?
Stingy.
Should we do for... Go for a tarot card?
Joker order should be chips, then multi-multi.
I see.
Well, this one doesn't really matter, I think.
Right?
I'll just... I'll put him there anyway.
This is frozen Jimbo.
Let's wait for a better... You guys, let's wait for a better Arcana pack.
Let's wait for one where we can pull two, okay?
Alright.
It's boss time.
Which one though?
Which one do I...
Steal?
This is the steal?
Okay.
Goodbye, goodbye, goodbye, goodbye.
Goodbye.
Yeah, let's check every heart.
It's okay though, it's okay.
We just need one more.
Full house?
I can't remember what full house... Oh, three of a kind and a pair.
No, no, let's go for four of a kind.
Four of a kind, baby.
Four of a kind!
Ah, nice.
I mean, we do have four of a kind, but we're trying to keep this in the hand, you know?
We're trying to keep it, we're trying to keep it.
Right?
Does it... Wait, does it stay?
Five of a kind.
Thank you!
Thank you so much!
Yeah, we want to keep it, we want to keep it.
Right?
Like, we want to play the four and then have this still in our hand, right?
That's how the multiplier works.
Right?
Yeah.
That's... That's what I'm talking about.
Maybe we can still do five of a kind.
Even though this one doesn't mean anything.
We can still do it.
One, two, three, four, five.
Give me my money.
What's our voucher?
I'm guessing there's a...
I'm guessing... I'm guessing there's an achievement for collecting all the vouchers.
Oh, surprise tool for later.
Destroys up to two selected cards.
Okay.
Level up straight flesh.
Buffalo!
Why is that one so shiny?
Oh, they're both pretty shiny.
Nevermind.
Guys, what if I buy Pokemon cards and open them on stream?
Hangman is quite useful.
So I can just destroy whatever I want.
That particular one you gotta buy 10 of to upgrade.
What?
RetroCandy, welcome to BibleShop.
Thank you!
Thins out your deck.
So we can just have only aces.
What if we get a boss that's just like...
All aces are...
Are obsolete.
Oh, I can get rid of some face cards.
Someone said Pokemon cards.
Alright,
let's try it.
Okay.
But it doesn't count as like a discard.
Okay, I understand now.
Hold on to it.
Yes.
We hold on to it.
FatalShot, welcome to BambooShip.
Thank you!
Okay.
I think I'm good right now on my jokers, so...
11,000!
22!
Oh my gosh.
Okay.
Wait.
Gives us free spectral pack.
I think I'm good.
Nice!
Hold on.
What is our thing?
Every heart card.
Okay.
Did you know that if you play cards, you might do something and that something might make you win?
No kidding.
I just realized I've been kind of blocking it a little bit.
I'll move over.
We'll get rid of the Noel, but I feel like I'm doing alright now.
Yeah, yeah, true.
You and you.
Goodbye!
I hung the people!
Cool.
But...
I'm trying to...
I'm trying to decide if I want to try for the multiplier ace.
Oh my god.
Well, actually, no, this is a multiplier ace.
I'm stupid.
Wait, but it's only when it stays in our hand.
But if we have a bunch of them in our hands...
Well, then we wouldn't be able to play anything, huh?
Nevermind.
Well, if we played a good ace, if we played like one of these and then had like four of these in our hand...
You know, it could work.
You could still play it, true.
$3400.
Okay, let's see.
I have two aces.
I feel like I'm only ace-minded now.
I don't even know what any other cards' hands are.
I don't know anything else anymore.
Wait, what was this?
Every heart card.
Okay, good.
This will give us...
That's your build?
Okay.
Cool.
Oh, we can keep... We can hold on to these maybe.
Can I just see?
Wait.
We wouldn't be so much wooded.
I'm just gonna see if I like could just play the tens and see what happens.
Like with all of these in my hand, like how much of a multiplier it would be.
Feed the castle.
Do
it?
Try it?
Let's see how much it is.
I'm just curious.
And then we'll discard...
These I'll discard.
Wait, I have a question.
If I play these but they don't do anything, does it count as discarding for the castle?
You know what I mean?
No.
Okay, it does not.
Okay, okay, okay.
Okay, okay.
It does not count.
Okay, okay, okay.
So I would have to play it and then...
We can do the four though.
Yeah, we can do the four.
Even though I was gonna attach... It doesn't really matter.
I was gonna attach that there anyway.
Alright,
now let's throw all of these away.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5.
Eat up, castle!
Okay,
I'm just gonna play this.
More discard?
You guys are so greedy!
Oh, I guess because I have another heart.
Okay, okay, okay.
Oh my god, what if I had pressed discard?
What if I had pressed it?
That would have been crazy.
It hungers.
Okay, okay.
I think
we might win.
Yippee!
Right click to deselect all by the way.
Ah, thank you.
Did not know that.
Yippee!
Level up two pair.
Okay.
Three dollars of discard is held in hand at the end of the round.
Arcana pack.
I guess this is better.
Is this her first run ever?
It is!
Should I do both of them?
Level up pair.
Do we have...Oh!
I was gonna say level up four of a kind!
Yeah baby!
Let's try.
Converts up to three selected cards to diamonds.
Creates two random planet cards.
Gives all...gives the total sell value of all current jokers.
Currently fifteen dollars.
Oh, I can get my money back.
What does it mean must have room?
Oh, like up here?
Two consumable slots.
I thought the planets were leveling up your four of a kind and the straight and everything like that.
Oh, they do.
Oh, but they are consumable.
Ah, okay, okay, okay.
Oh, I thought that you just...I need to get my money back.
Try a reroll.
Play cards with odd rank.
Give plus 31 chips when scored.
What's holographic?
Fancy!
Wait, it counts aces?
Wait...
Oh yeah, it does.
Because it's holographic it's a plus ten multiplier.
Um...
What would be best to get rid of though?
Maybe Blue Junkler?
We get rid of Ice Minky for Holographic Minky.
Okay, sayonara.
Buy and use.
Wow.
We've purchased everything.
Reorder.
Here the chippies go first, right?
But the multiplier...
Wouldn't the multiplier go at the...
Wait, oh, but it's a ten...oh, nevermind.
Plus ten.
It's not a times.
Yeah, so I think this one would be good at the top.
Because then it would multiply and then it would add more.
And then they'll multiply from there.
Oh my gosh!
Pen to ice!
Wait...
Yeah!
Okay!
Gives five dollars per skipped blind.
This run.
Oh, so it would give me five dollars.
Okay.
Select.
Wouldn't it be better maybe to get the Ice of Hearts?
We still have the bus.
We still have our bus driver, so...
We'll just...
We'll just get rid of this for now.
Discard.
Wait, what's our thing?
Every heart card?
We're still riding the bus, babe.
We'll keep the five.
Discard.
We might have to do it.
We'll see.
Guys, it's not looking so good.
Guys,
it's not... Are we cooked?
We thought, we thought, we thought...
Let's do this one, because I think we have a ton of...
Of the Ace of Diamonds.
And we only have one of the spades, so we'll do the spade.
You want them the same?
No, no!
You do, but you don't.
Because, because...
If I'm in a battle, if I'm in a boss battle and it says all diamonds are useless...
If it says all diamonds are useless, then I am screwed.
You have to think.
We need the diversity.
1, 2, 3, 4.
And...
You beat that boss already.
Wait.
Did they not come back?
Eventually?
Boss blind, don't repeat.
How am I supposed to know that?
Wait a second.
I'll just play this guy too.
We'll get all the bonuses.
Well, now you do.
RIP Flush5, it's fine.
I'm in.
You guys, look how much money I'm in.
Why, Vtuber, why?
Seed chat.
It's the highest hand ever.
You guys see how many I have?
We'll get it again.
I'll do it next time.
Baseball.
Uncommon jokers give 1.5.
Free money.
More free money.
Buy and use.
How much would that be?
Does rare count?
Rare doesn't count for baseball.
Damn.
I only just found out now that boss battles don't repeat literally just now.
I guess you haven't gotten that far, huh?
Voucher is better.
It doesn't do anything.
Buy the voucher?
Voucher?
Really?
Get the blankets worth?
I feel like I'm getting gas lit here.
I feel like I'm being told to buy the Pekojuice in the Holocure Casino.
Buy it for progress.
I'm getting scammed.
My grandma just called me and she's just like...
Help!
It's me, Minto!
I need your bank account information!
Because I've been kidnapped by the Mafia!
Okay grandma, I'll get you out of there.
How do I help?
Send me 20 Walmart gift cards!
It's the only currency they accept!
Let's try a planet.
You are the grandma here.
Straight, flush, three of a kind.
Actually, three of a kind might be good in case our luck is bad.
My bank account number...
No!
Made of time!
Flush?
You think the flush?
It was a flush.
Five cards that share the same unit.
Here is one gift card.
I'll get the rest later.
Trust.
Thanks Jamie.
Grandma is waiting for it.
I think three of a kind though, right?
Just in case we only get three aces or something.
If something goes wrong, I feel this would be better.
I'm gonna do it.
I'm not listening to you guys.
I think three is safe.
Should I try the Arcana path?
No error.
Increases rank of two cards selected by one.
If only I had a king!
Destroys up to two selected cards.
This one could be good though.
Converts up to three selected cards of diamonds to spades.
We have sixteen dollars.
But we can get our money back.
Fin the low numbers.
I guess that's fair.
Wait, can I... Does this have to be used right now?
I could destroy these.
Oh no.
Goodbye multi-card.
No...
Immediate use for packs.
This is our deck right now.
This is what we got.
We're thinning out the family.
The royal family is going down.
Cards drawn face down after each hand played.
What?
We have
four.
So I'm guessing they're all going to flip upside down.
These ones will come in upside down.
But if I sort them by rank, we'll be okay.
We just have to...
Kind of.
These cards aren't in place.
Wait, what's our thing?
Heart.
What was it that... Oh, diamond, right?
That I was trying to get the flush...
The five of a flush.
Oh look, it's on there now.
It was heart, right?
Goodbye!
We're trying for it.
We're going for it.
One more.
This is it.
This is it!
This is my first stream in Mint's lab so I'm living in infectious.
Thank you!
Welcome RetroCandy!
Thanks for the superchat.
Came in to see, not sure what's going on, but get better soon.
I'm better!
I'm so good now.
No!
I'm not better.
This is, everything sucks.
Wait, how does it... Everybody sucks!
Everybody sucks!
You don't really know what...
Okay, let's see.
How do we want to do this?
Let's keep this in the hand.
One, two, three.
We can get rid of these.
Why though?
Oh the bus!
You're right, thank you.
Thank you, I almost forgot.
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
You guys saved me!
The bus was going to crash!
Play hand.
Four of a kind?
I want to see if we can get the four of a kind here.
Am I being too risky?
Should I just play all of them?
I know what the boss is.
Cards drawn face down after each hand played.
I know.
I read.
But if anything is in front of this guy, we know that it's... Well, not anything.
I wish he were a king.
Okay, maybe I don't want to risk it.
Oh, what?
Fine!
Four is better.
Oh, okay.
Oh yeah, we did level up four.
True.
Oh yeah, true, true, true.
Okay, play.
Is there a planet to level up five of a kind?
Yes?
We'll just have to get that.
Twelve bucks!
Smile.
Oh, minus one ante, minus one hand each round.
Huh?
We got this guy again.
Place face cards, give...
But it's not as good as this one.
It's not as good as this one.
Resets back a round.
Vouchers too big brain for first round.
Millions, millions, welcome to Mambo Ship.
Thank you!
I imagine this can be used...
to farm stuff, money, planets, arcanas I imagine.
Let's open stuff.
Gotcha!
Flush.
Well there you guys go.
The flush, right?
It's not a straight flush, but it is a flush.
We'll do the flush.
Wait, what was the other one?
High card.
Oh wait, high card for when we...
play our first ace, right?
Nevermind.
Select two cards, convert the left card into the right card.
No!
I wish I could...can I move these?
What are the other ones though?
Enhances two selected cards to lucky cards.
Are these not lucky enough?
They're bonus cards, but what's a lucky card?
1 in 5 chance for plus 20.
1 in 15 chance to win $20.
Creates up to two random tarot cards.
Before I select this...
Oh, drag to rearrange.
I'm an idiot.
I did read this and I have moved this correctly, right?
Converts the left card into the right card.
Yes!
They cannot be both lucky and a bonus.
I see, thank you.
Use.
Maybe I should have done like a 2 or something.
Like a low number.
Oh well, whatever.
Thank you for the 20 gift.
Thank you!
Alright, next round.
What do we give?
We skip.
Free spectral pack.
Nice!
Ring, ring, ring.
I
wonder if we can get the all diamonds.
Discard!
Flush 5.
We're trying.
Discard!
We have the 4.
Alright.
Last chance.
One card.
Just one.
Single.
Card.
To get the ace of diamonds.
Discard the left ace.
Discard the ace, Mito!
It's ok, I think we still win.
I think we still win.
Mega pack!
Oh, hi Blue Joker.
Oh gosh, this is awkward.
Hi Blue Joker!
Oh gosh, we haven't seen you in a while.
Let's open some packs.
Straight flush.
3 of a kind.
Straight.
But straight is...no.
Pluto.
I think we should do Mars and Pluto, right?
Straight flush.
3 of a kind.
We don't
do the consecutives anymore.
We have our...we basically have our build.
It's not perfect, but it's pretty good.
Always invest in high card, baby.
I'm so used to the game speed being at max that your game seems so slow.
What?
It can go...what?
It feels fast to me.
Faster!
Planet card go!
Mars?
5 of a kind.
I found it.
Planet X.
Full house.
Flush.
Sorry, I know I check these all the time, but it's because I can't remember.
5 cars share the same unit.
Everybody wants Planet X.
2 pair.
Flush or...Planet X, I feel.
I mean Mars is also very tempting.
Planet X!
I've never seen Planet X.
Really?
It hasn't been discovered in your solar system yet.
Adds 1 voucher.
That's kind of exciting.
Lights.
Wait, I like watching the numbers...
The numbers went up too fast.
Wait!
It's too fast.
I like watching the numbers go up.
What if I put it at 0.5?
Ok, ok, ok.
Let's see.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5.
What's our castle?
It's a heart.
What if I accidentally...
It's very...Joker unlocked?
Wait, what was that?
Driver's license.
Olivia Rodrigo.
I feel like I should just do the 4.
The bus driver has a license now.
I wasn't driving before!
But maybe we should try for...
Let's do the 4.
Our 4 of a kind is level 4.
So it's pretty strong I feel.
Enhances 1 selected card to a steel card.
Crazy Joker.
When small blind or big blind is selected, gain 0.5 multiplier and destroy a random Joker.
Craziness.
More steel.
I
currently can't fathom how this card would be...
I mean, obviously I see the multiplier as a bonus, but...
What?
Alright, let's do...
You know what?
What if we get an ace?
If not, we can just skip it, right?
If I don't get the ace?
Crazy is good if you get it really early.
Let's do the Celestial Pack first.
Pluto or Planet X?
Planet X!
Ace!
AB!
Ace...
That's awkward.
Skip a skip.
Yeah, because I have a full deck.
Since I have 61 out of 61 cards...
Wait, can I... I can't get more cards, right?
Like I'd have to... Oh yeah, I was going to buy the Chariot.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Oh, you can?
It would go to 62.
Oh, okay.
No repeat hand types this round.
Okay.
Heart card.
But what if...
We got the fifth one.
I'm going to do...
Okay, hold on.
I'm going to play these two.
And throw this away.
So that we can have three chances.
Wait, wait.
Oh no!
I tried.
If you get the fifth one, I'll propose.
Well, Evan, you're safe today.
Reroll boss blind one time per ante.
Ten dollars per roll.
Stingy!
Ten dollars?
Everybody's saying to get it.
Oh, director's cut.
Let's see this one.
Plus one hand type!
Oh wait, I don't have any room.
Minus four multiplier per round played.
I like castle.
It's hungry.
Early game joker.
Yeah, let's buy some packs.
Wait, can you have a full stone deck?
Broken stone.
Wow, glass card.
I've never seen that one before.
You can!
One in four chance to destroy card.
Oh no, that's so scary!
It counts as a high card.
What do you mean, just a plus fifty?
Okay, well...
That would be exciting if it was like...
Whatever you paired it with, it kind of was...
But I guess not.
Let's try this one.
Oh, I unlocked it.
I unlocked a deck.
I don't know what I...
Nice.
Oh, he also gained a multi... Oh my god!
This guy is so powerful.
Holy moly.
Gives five dollars... I always want to click this first.
Five dollars per skip the blind.
No!
We were so close to beating that.
First time.
The hologram is getting... He's getting big.
What's our thing?
Diamond.
We'll still win.
One, two, three, four, five.
We'll still win, it's fine.
The flash vibe, baby!
Reserved parking.
Oh, moon.
Converts up to three selected cards to clubs.
Oh, I forgot to use this.
Oopsie.
Each face card held in hand has a one in two chance to give a doll.
Oh, face card go away.
I thought you spent the last round, Evan.
It's all about sending a message with a flash vibe.
Exactly.
Let's buy some cards.
Choose one.
Destroys up to two selected cards.
I could do that.
Enhances two selected cards to...
Oh, all my aces are taken though.
Converts up to... Soon we're going to have all aces.
And we're going to have to strategize what kind of aces we get.
Oh my god.
What was the sign?
Converts up to three into heart.
My friends hate it when I play Flush 5 on Poker Night.
Goodbye.
Turn them all.
Only aces allowed.
Convert it all to one suit.
What if I just thin out my hand?
I think it'll be better.
Down with the royal family.
That's okay.
Hi Minto.
Hello Rem.
Open.
Mars.
Earth.
Flush.
Question.
How many levels are there for the planets?
Infinite?
Our Flush 4 is kind of...
Wait.
What was the moon?
My bad.
I forgot what it was anyway.
Mega buffoon.
Oh, the clubs.
Yeah, yeah.
Thank you.
Okay.
Heart.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5.
In the club.
What the heck?
Where is my steel?
1, 2, 3, 4.
Discard.
Still no steel.
Oh, the chariot.
Can turn into steel.
We do have this guy just kind of chilling over here.
Ears.
Okay, I got my steel.
Easy.
1, 2, 3.
Discard.
Oh, come on.
Where were you?
We can... 1, 2, 3, 4.
5?
Take the 5?
Yeah, true.
5.
We've actually... We've upgraded our 5 of a kind, so...
It'll be big money.
Big money.
Holy... Oh my god.
I didn't think that kind of big money.
Converts 3 to diamond.
What does this guy have?
3.5.
Each played card with spade suits gives 1.5.
Suit changes at the end of the round.
This one might be good to switch out.
Not... Say it's like a diamond.
We have so many ace diamonds.
Would it not be so good?
It's risky.
Is it?
I have a question.
Would they all have to be the same?
Or is it like... I play a hand with like one spade.
Oh, they have to be the same.
No?
Wait, huh?
So each...
No, it's just card by card.
Then why wouldn't it be good?
Why?
It changes.
Yeah, I know, but like...
I use spade as the example because it's written right there.
Because it's always changing.
But I have...
It's good, but castle is better?
Okay, I'll trust you guys.
I'm not quite understanding what the issue is.
I'm not quite understand... Okay, so for example...
If I put down... We're doing four of a kind.
It's ace of spades...
Ace of... And three ace of hearts, right?
Ace of spades, three ace of hearts is what we got, right?
Say it's a multiplier with spade.
Would I not get 1.5 times multiplied then?
You'd get 1.5.
Yeah, wouldn't that be good?
Wouldn't that be better than the 93 chips?
You guys are saying yes, but keep feeding the castle.
It's just inconsistent.
Okay!
The DNA has done its job?
No, it's not.
The DNA is not finished yet.
The DNA remains.
Because I might not just want to duplicate the steel cards.
I might want to duplicate every card.
You get it?
I agree with you because it could be good.
That's it!
It's fine though.
Three of a kind.
Straight.
Full house.
Two pair.
Straight flush.
Straight flush we could do, right?
No.
No, not straight flush.
I was thinking of something else.
I was just thinking of the flush.
No!
I was thinking of just the flush.
We'll do the three of a kind then.
Maybe?
I guess so.
I'm not going to waste it.
Mega standard.
Why does it look like that?
Wild card?
Can be used as any suit?
Any...
Skip.
Four flushes.
I mean we could get a card to feed the Joker, true?
True, true, true.
True?
I guess it doesn't really matter what.
We'll just throw it away.
And we get to feed two.
We get to choose two of them.
But the consistency, I know.
It hurts me too.
Trust me, it hurts me too.
You can strength to turn the queens into aces.
That is enough to sell me.
Next round!
The boss.
First hand is drawn.
OK, this one.
Discard everything?
OK, so these are our aces.
Now we know.
See, I think I might... I want to play this one so I can get more of him too, you know what I mean?
But this is a boss round, so we must play smart.
Order by suit?
Oh, I don't like that.
Sorry, I don't like that.
Let me just throw these away.
Go away.
And you also go away.
Oh, I played it out of...
Wait, this one?
Oh shoot, I wasn't paying attention.
This one is a steal card.
I don't remember which other steal card it was.
I don't...
The two on the left are the steal?
By
rank?
That's what I...
Oh, steal is the toughest... is the bestest?
I see, I see.
Exploding Otome!
So welcome to my village and thank you!
And that's a win baby!
Yeah!
Achievement unlocked.
Oh, anti-8!
Sad.
Oh my gosh, this is an actual jungler.
Create a tarot card if hand is played with $4 to let know.
Wild card.
Rerolls cost $2 less.
Cardboard jungler.
He's like actually from the movie, the jungler.
Good voucher.
Oh my gosh, wait, I'm almost out of money.
I need to stop spending so much.
Jumbo.
Wild card would be good on one of our aces, wouldn't it?
The palacho is the friend we made along the way.
Kana for free.
Free money?
We don't know if we will.
Wild card overrides other buff.
Okay, nevermind.
Understood.
Big pack!
Let's see.
Doubles money!
I could get more money.
1 in 4 chance to add a foil holographic or polychrome addition to a random joker.
Creates up to 2 random tarot cards.
Creates up to 2 random planet cards.
The wheel.
Select 2 cards.
Wait.
But death.
The wheel never works.
The wheel is a trap.
Oh it's not even like a... You guys, it's a 25% chance.
With my luck?
Wait, but isn't the wheel like a meme?
I think I've heard of this one at least.
I want to do it for the meme.
If I get it...
You owe me 5 bucks.
Don't believe them.
Do the wheel.
Rob, thank you for owning up.
Noah, thank you for owning up.
WakeUpBlack, thank you for owning up.
SeaMaru, thank you for owning up.
EvanDix, thank you for owning up.
I should have made it higher.
Doubters and Shambles.
Thank you guys!
The wheel works every time baby!
A deal is a deal.
Sorry, I still have a bit of a cough.
Hold on, let me take some throat stuff real quick.
I have some throat direct from Japan.
It's all green!
It's all mint though.
Thank you guys.
We love the wheel.
I think I'm gonna save my money.
I didn't believe and I accidentally made a timestamp for you hitting a nope even though it wasn't.
Thank you for the double contribution then.
Oh my gosh you guys, thank you!
Thank you, thank you.
Alrighty.
Let's do the next round!
Plus three hand size.
We can do this.
One random joker disabled every hand.
Oh that's scary!
Wait, I don't know if we can do this.
What did this do?
What did the foil do anyway?
Did the foil even do anything?
Did it just make it shiny?
Oh, plus 50 chips.
Wow, this hand sucks.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5.
Get out of here.
There we go.
1, 2... Oh my god!
I'm just gonna play this guy.
Feed the castle.
Diamond.
The flex.
2, 3, 4, wait.
Guys, I could even discard these.
That would be kind of crazy, right?
To feed the castle.
We'll still win.
1, 2, 3, 4.
Oh, the flush 5?
Okay, okay, okay.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5.
There you guys go.
There you guys go, the overkill.
The overkill, absolutely.
We only needed less than 500.
Plus 80 chips if played hand contains 2 pair.
In sickness and in health?
lol
Streamer luck tax.
I don't know about that.
Thank you, Retro.
Choose one of the planets.
Choose the wheel.
Eric, thanks for the gift.
Keep 10 for boss re-roll.
Oh, we could boss re-roll, right?
Okay.
I'm assuming that I re-roll when the boss comes up, right?
Super memetism.
Wait, I can re-roll now?
Don't, it's fine.
I don't know.
You think it's doable?
There are scarier bosses, I believe.
But like, what if I lose?
What if I lose one of my big multipliers?
I don't know, we might still be able to do it.
We might have like a big hand of...
The multiply ones with...
When you have them in your hand, you know?
Only for one round.
Like
this one.
My cough is starting to get bad, so...
Maybe once I beat the boss, I'll finish it off.
Was there a spade?
Oh, we don't have that.
Discard.
Nice suit.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5.
Wait, he hungers.
Box, thanks.
Thanks for joining membership.
Thank you.
Ok, last one.
Oh, ok.
1, 2, 3, 4...
I'm such an idiot, whatever.
There we go.
Steel has no bonus when played.
I know.
Oh!
Plus 20 multiplier of...
If played, hand contains 3 or fewer cards.
Green.
One free re-roll, poor shop.
To a standard pack.
Evan, it's ok.
Stand down.
Stand down, Evan.
Re-roll.
Saturn.
As the number of times poker hand has been played to this run...
Wait, poker hand?
What's this poker hand?
Oh wow, we're in here now.
Look at run info.
Oh, just this?
Wait, as the number of times poker hand has been played to...
Oh, so the poker hand changes.
Blink.
Thank you for the time gifter.
Thank you.
Ok guys.
I think we're gonna do the boss now.
Actually, let's open up a card pack.
I don't know, my cough has not been so bad.
So I apologize.
Guys.
Let's just go into it.
One random joker is disabled.
Castle!
That honestly is our best...
Is our...
Is the best one that could be disabled.
Yeah, let's go castle!
He has a tummy ache.
Oh.
But,
it's gonna change into something else.
But this will give us a big advantage until then.
Oh, not as big as I imagined.
Oh, wait!
Oh my god.
Let's go!
Let's go.
I guess we'll just do one, two, three.
Which is better?
Five of a kind?
What?
Or four of a kind?
Oh wait, five of a kind is technique...
Wait, what's the times 18 times 19?
The base multiplier.
Ah, I see, I see, I see.
So five...
My math.
I can't do that math.
Five is slightly better now.
Five is slightly better.
I think we might be able to win.
We won!
My cough is not very good.
I'm gonna go take some medicine you guys.
Sorry.
I don't have any water.
But we won!
First try baby!
I can't talk so much though.
Seed.
Tutorial.
Okay,
I really gotta go guys.
I'm so sorry.
I'm so sorry but...
I wanted to talk some more.
But I gotta go.
Okay.
Tutorial was fun.
I actually like Bellatio.
I'll see you guys later.
Otsumito, bye bye!
Bye bye.